[Music]
it is the bestselling book in history no
volume ever written has been more loved
and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previous
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 800
835-6771
6747 now here's your host from amazing
facts International Pastor Doug Bachelor
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact on March 8th
2014 Malaysia Airlines flight 370
departed from koala Lumar International
Airport heading to Beijing China with
227 passengers and 12 crew aboard about
38 minutes after takeoff while over the
South China Sea the Boeing 777 aircraft
dropped from Air Traffic Control radar
the Malaysian military picked up the
aircraft 17 minutes later observing that
it had attempted a nearly complete
U-turn but there was no response from
the cockpit after flying back over
Malaysia the Deb mysteriously turned and
eventually disappeared from radar as it
headed south into the most remote
section of the Indian Ocean The
Disappearance of flight 370 triggered a
massive multi-international surge by air
and sea in Asia and the southern Indian
Ocean that's estimated to have covered
some 46,000 square miles the search that
began in
2014 was finally concluded on June 9
2018 costing an estimate ated $160
million making it the longest and most
expensive search in history in 2015 a
few pieces of debris believed to be from
the plane washed up on Reunion Island in
the Indian Ocean confirming it had
crashed into the sea still the plane's
location blackbox or none of the
passengers were ever found nor did they
ever discovered the reason for the
disaster you know that just that's
heart-wrenching when you think of all
those people's lives that were shattered
and um no answers and there was actually
years before a year and a half before
they found any debris and they you know
there were all kinds of conspiracies and
that had been hijacked or was it a a
blackmailing plot and and um it just it
was heart-wrenching for the families
involved but you look at all of the time
and the money that was spent searching
for the Lost you know it's so important
for them whenever these disasters occur
especially in aviation they want to find
out the cause of what caused the
accident so that they could learn from
that you know modify things sometimes
they have to change things related to
the plane in this case was all all of
that money and time they come up with I
mean maybe theories but they don't have
any concrete evidence to support an idea
and so they haven't learned from that
experience and to think about it the
amount of money and the amount of time
well you remember I remember it well
when when the plane went missing and uh
everyone was pretty confident at first
with the modern technology and with the
satellites and being able to trace
things they everyone thought they'd find
the plane but it just kept going on and
the black box it it's you know developed
it's extremely it's indestructible
virtually and it it emits a um a
locating Beacon and uh but it was such a
remote place and they think so deep they
never found it it but it makes me think
about you know all that time and energy
spent to save the lost but it wasn't
really the most expensive search because
the Bible tells us about the most
expensive search the most expensive
search costs the most expensive thing
and that would be the life of the
Creator nothing's more valuable than
that and if you say you got a mountain
of diamonds what's worth more a mountain
of diamonds or the one who can make a
mountain of diamonds so the Lord sent
his son into the world to seeking to
save the lost by the way that's Luke
19:9 and 10 Jesus said and this isn't
the story of zakus today salvation has
come to his house because he is also a
son of Abraham for the son of man has
come to seek and to save that which is
lost and then in chapter 15 of Luke
Jesus said in verse 4 what man of you
having a hundred sheep if he loses one
of them does not leave the 90 and9 in
the wilderness and go after the one that
is lost until he finds it and when he
finds it he lays it on his shoulders
rejoicing
and this is how desperately the Lord
yearns to redeem his lost
children you know the amazing thing
about the Plan of Redemption it costs so
much and yet so many people spur this
great gift even though it's at infinite
cost and of course we have to respond
the price has been paid but by faith we
need to receive that gift of Salvation
we have a book it's called three steps
to Heaven what do we do to benefit from
this great seek and save this this Mercy
mission from Heaven we'll be happy to
send this to anyone just call and ask
three steps to Heaven that's our free
gift today call
8835 6747 ask for offer number
102 and we'll be happy to send it to you
anywhere here in North America if you're
outside of the us we want to encourage
you to go to our website
amazingfacts.org and you'll be able to
read the book right there online well we
have many uh folks lined up with their
calls Pastor Doug but let's St with
prayer and then we go to the phone lines
dear father we thank you thank you once
again that we have this opportunity to
study your word together and Lord we ask
your blessing upon this program guide us
into a clear and full understanding of
the Bible as we study together in Jesus
name amen amen well we're going to go
first to Debbie in Canada Debbie welcome
to the program you're on the air hi
pastors how are you doing great how are
you I'm very well thank you I have a
question okay and it's about when Moses
was told that he was not allow to cross
over to the promised land now in
Deuteronomy 4 or Deuteronomy 3:26 and
4:21 it says the Lord was angry with him
but we have a debate going on in the
YouTube and there's three of us that
think three different things and was
wondering if you could tell us which not
not so much which one is right but why
he wasn't allowed to cross over I hope
you'll all still be friends after I
share my answer and I could be totally
we will be all right now so um you're
talking about when it says the Lord was
angry with me on your account and would
not listen to me so the Lord said enough
of that speak to me no more of this
matter so he was pleading that he could
lead physically lead the people into the
promised land and so are you wondering
why was the Lord
angry yes what was he like we one of us
are saying it's because he killed the
Egyptian Soldier one of us are saying
because he broke the first set of
Commandments and the third one is saying
because he told them to speak to the
Rock in instead Moses struck the rock
yeah and that's that's a correct answer
is in numbers 20 verse2 it says the Lord
spoke to Moses and Aaron said because
you did not believe me and hallow me in
the eyes of the children of Israel
therefore you shall not bring this
assembly into the land that I've given
them God had told Moses to they were
pleading for water again he told Moses
to go and to speak to the Rock but Moses
got angry and he struck the rock twice
and say sh we bring ye Rebels water from
the Rock and he basically made it sound
like he and Aaron were doing it took the
glory from and he lost his
temper and um uh you know God said it's
not you that's been leading them all
this time it's me and he says because he
didn't sanctify me now to mitigate that
keep in mind why God said you couldn't
physically bring them into the promised
land uh the Lord let Moses see the
promised land from the top of Mount Nebo
he could look over and God enhance his
vision where he saw it all and then God
resurrected Moses you read that in Jude
verse 9 so that he could witness their
being led over so he saw it from Heaven
uh with the Lord at his side so it was a
tough sentence but Moses also represents
Jesus and what it says he was angry with
me for your sake that's what it says
regarding Christ it says that the Lord
basically took the anger that belongs to
us and put it on Jesus so Moses is a
type of Christ in this story as well and
of course Moses did eventually stand in
the promised land at the time when he
and Elijah yeah mount of transfiguration
they were there m so he did ultimately
walk in that land all right thank you
Debbie we've got kamora listening in
Georgia kamora welcome to the
program okay hi hello like
I have a question
yeah um I'm young and I'm considering
College After High School and um my mom
and a church sister and another church
sister is I'm working on trying to get
me to college like how do I know like
which college to go to all right so well
when you're you're trying to make
decisions and you've got several
potentially good choices and you want to
know what is God's will for me then uh
there's several criteria uh the Bible
tells us and by the way I've I've got a
little book we'll send you a free copy
if you'd like and it's called how to
know or how to determine the will of God
and it's designed especially for uh this
kind of question but and I won't give
you all everything in the book but it's
basically um get good Christian
counsel uh look for providential
openings find which of the options lines
up best with the word of God and um you
know uh pray that uh God's spirit will
give you peace and then also it says in
Psalms 37 that as you surrender to the
Lord he gives you the desires of your
heart so he may place place a you know
special burning desire on your heart for
a specialty and one college does more in
that specialty than another that would
be another sign so there's about a dozen
ideas in the book about how do I
determine the will of God and they're
all bible-based then uh you could send
for a free copy of that and we'll be
praying for you that God tells you what
to do Kamar the book is called
determining the will of God and for
anyone wanting to get the book you can
well two ways to get it one you can call
800 835
6747 and you can ask for the book or
there is a second way just dial pound
250 on your smartphone and say Bible
aners live and then ask for the book
it's called determining the will of God
and we'll be able to send that to anyone
who calls and uh asks for it next caller
that we have is Ron listening all the
way over in Switzerland Ron welcome to
the
program hi good morning Hi how are you
doing morning here yeah I call on behalf
of radio 74 listeners across Europe and
North America and uh this is about the
modern state of Israel a lot of my
Evangelical friends point out to the
numerous Old Testament Bible texts that
seem to support the notion of Jews as a
race remaining favored and under God's
protection forever and I always thought
that these Old Testament prophecies were
conditional and would be an noed if
conditions attached to them were not met
in other words repentance turning from
sin to Messiah as prophesied in Daniel 9
but I I haven't seen that happening so I
mean most Jews that I know are aren't
even Jewish they're atheists so uh my
question is how should one read Old
Testament prophecies concerning Israel
and are there any scriptures that
mention the modern state of Israel yeah
great question um you know Pastor Ross
and I just did a special program Friday
night talking about the war of Israel
and prophecy and I think we looked like
there was about
240,000 views already on that one site
we we deal with some of that there but
and by the way Ron it's good to hear
from you I know I I've been with you
there in Switzerland and and glad you're
calling in
um it's it's a complex answer first of
all the main purpose of Israel was to
introduce the Messiah to the world which
they did they were the Guardians of the
scriptures uh Paul says in Romans that
the oracles were committed to the Jews
and Jesus told the woman at the well
salvation is of the Jews meaning that
you know the Messiah came through the
Jews but um then with the death of
Christ and the stoning of Steven uh it
it came to the place where the Lord
opened the door to the Gentiles Paul
said you know it's it was necessary that
we preach to the Jews first but seeing
you reject it l we turn to the Gentiles
so as they went from place to place as
the Jews might reject some some accepted
like in Berea but if they rejected then
they just went to the Gentiles and then
Paul makes it clear he says you know now
Gentiles can be grafted into the stock
and Promises of Israel that's Romans
chapter
91011 but it says in Romans 11 has God
cast off Israel God forbid U God God
still has I think a special eye on the
Jewish people that doesn't mean anyone
is saved by virtue of their DNA or their
Heritage it's those that are Faith Paul
says he that is Christ's he is Abraham's
seed and it's not everyone that says you
know they're a Jew Jesus said they'll
come from the East and the west and
they'll sit down in the Kingdom with
Abraham Isaac and Jacob and some of the
natural children will be in outer
Darkness so it we're only saved by faith
Jew or Gentile but are there any modern
prophecies about Israel well you know
there some have wondered when it says
there in Daniel and I'm just saying what
some have thought Daniel 11 where it
says that the U the the King of the
North is going to come against the holy
country the Glorious country they wonder
is that an illusion to Israel or is it
talking about the church and then you
have in Luke 21 where it says Jerusalem
would be trotten down by the Gentiles
until the times of the Gentiles is
fulfilled and many have thought well
when they were reestablished as a nation
in 1948 that was certainly pretty
remarkable it may be in the same way God
chastised America to get to turn us back
to him with 911 you know even Billy
Graham said maybe God's trying to get
our attention it may be this recent uh
attack the lord loves his people and
sometimes he allows trials that will
turn to him and U so that may have
sounded like a convoluted answer we have
a book on this
called spiritual Israel and there's also
that great book the fall and Rise of
Jerusalem that's right well let me tell
you about that free offer it's called
spiritual Israel and again this is for
anyone who'd like to learn more about
what does the Bible say about Israel
especially in our time to receive that
just call 800 835 6747 you can ask for
the book it's called spiritual Israel
you can also dial pound 250 on your
smartphone say Bible answers live ask
for Spiritual Israel and as Pastor Doug
mentioned I'm going to hold this up
right here we got something that we
don't always offer but it is a great
offer that we have a book pretty good
siiz book called the fall and the rise
of Jerusalem and this is free for anyone
wanting to receive this book read it
share it with a friend uh again just
call 800 83567 47 ask for the book the
fall and the rise of Jerusalem and we'll
be able to get that to you thanks Ron
next caller that we have is Anna
listening in Aran Anna welcome to the
program evening pastors
evening my question is from Ezekiel
34: 23 and 24 and I was wondering if
Ezekiel is talking about Jesus when he
says
that
David my servant David he shall feed
them and be their
Shepherd yeah I I I think this is let me
read it for everybody here and this is
uh in Ezekiel uh 34:23
I will establish one Shepherd over them
and he will feed them my servant David
he will feed them and be their Shepherd
and I the Lord will be their God and my
servant David a prince among them as I
the Lord have spoken this is what you
would call a dual prophecy I do believe
that David will be in the the new Heaven
and the new Earth where it says the meek
will inherit the earth and God's you
know David he always looked at the
people of Israel as his sheep when a
terrible plague came he said Lord what
have these sheep done take this out on
me and my father's house so I think
David will have a position of leadership
in the earth made new but more than that
I think it's talking about Jesus the son
of David who is the Good Shepherd and
Jesus said I am the Good Shepherd and he
is the son of David so in a bigger sense
I think it's talking about Christ and
probably again the book that we
mentioned just previous called spiritual
Israel talk on this as well so again to
receive that it's 800 835 6747 or just
dial pound 250 say Bible answers live
ask for the book it's called spiritual
Israel we've got Glenn listening in Ohio
Glenn welcome to Bible answers
live good evening and thank you for
taking my call yes sir you know Paul in
his book of 1 Thessalonians 4:17 was
pretty specific when he said the dead in
Christ rise and then we which are alive
and remain but there's 4,000 years of
people that are that existed before the
Jesus era my question is what
Resurrection will they be
in yeah the you can read in Revelation
chapter 20 speaking of the general
resurrection and it describes there are
two resurrections when I first read this
I thought what I thought everyone just
got raised at the end for judgment but
Jesus says uh and I'm quoting two
different verses Jesus says in the
gospel of John the hour is coming in
which all that are in the graves will
hear his voice and come forth they that
have done good the resurrection of life
and he says and they that have done evil
the resurrection of damnation two
different resurrections and you read in
Revelation chapter 20 and this is
talking about you know the Millennium
and it says that
um oh let me see I want verse five the
rest of the Dead live not again until
the thousand years are finished well who
are the rest of the Dead well it says
the dead in Christ rise when Jesus comes
so all believers from the time of Abel
and Adam all the way to um the second
coming with a you know a few exceptions
like Enoch and Elijah
Moses um they sleep until the second
coming when the Lord descends from
heaven with a shout in the voice of the
Archangel and the Trump of God and they
rise the wicked do not come out of their
grave it says the rest of the Dead they
come out after the thousand years and
then he goes on and says blessed and
holy is he that has part in the first
resurrection well where you've got a
first resurrection you must have a
second first resurrection is righteous
second Resurrection is the
lost and we have a study guide talking
about it important subject so it's
called the ultimate Deliverance talking
about the second coming of Christ and
talks about that resurrection of the
righteous at the second coming and then
the resurrection of of the wicked at the
third coming at the end of the 1,000
years so actually two study guides the
one's called the ultimate Deliverance
talking about the second coming then we
have another one called a thousand years
of peace talks about the Millennium and
then what happens at the end of that the
number to call is 8835 6747 that is our
resource phone line ask for that study
guide the ultimate deliverance and also
a th years of peace or dial pound 250
say Bible answers live and just ask for
those resources next caller that we have
is Steve listening in Oregon Steve
you're on the
air yes I've recently received one of
your DVD programs expounding on the
millions and billions of stars and
galaxies in our universe and also
stating in the Kingdom to come we will
be able to visit other worlds if I
understand
uh this correctly could it be possible
if what we might be witnessing today of
UF UFOs that are from other worlds that
did not flunk the test of sin that Adam
and Eve
failed yeah well i' separate that
question first I'd say do we believe
there's intelligent life in other
world's unfallen worlds I think
absolutely and you can read in the book
of Hebrews chapter 1 the second verse of
the book of Hebrews it says God has in
these last days spoken to us by his son
whom he has appointed heir of all things
through whom also he made the worlds and
it's plural there and then you read in
Revelation about all the creatures on
Earth and all the creatures above are
praising God um Book of Job talks about
this heavenly meeting that is not on
Earth where Satan also comes among them
and he says I've come from the earth so
is there intelligent life outside of
planet Earth absolutely they Cosmos is
virtually infinite and God is infinite
so I think it's silly to say we are the
first time God thought to create
anything U you know 6,000 years ago but
the unfallen worlds um I think our
planet is quarantined because of sin the
only interaction we have is with the
hospital staff that' be God and the
angels so um I don't think you know if
there's UFOs and people are seeing
things it could be optical illusions or
it could be demonic I mean Satan can
he's an angel of Light sometimes Satan
can create Illusions and delusions so I
hope that helps a little bit but uh what
do you think Pastor Ross yeah absolutely
you know I'm looking Pastor de do we
have a book talking about UFOs we might
have to get one because we do get a lot
of question yeah of course the Bible
does say you I have a Ser I'm sorry go
ahead I was just going to mention the
Bible does say that the devil can
transform himself into an angel of Light
so y wouldn't be very hard for him to
you use these UFOs and if you look at at
least the popular idea what a UFO is or
an alien um it always presents them as
as very strange and uh you know not with
head yeah I mean they're not exactly
Angelic beings so you know I have a
sermon online if you just YouTube um
Doug Bachelor uh is there life on other
worlds and uh it's a few years ago so I
look much better then but it's actually
I think a good message taking what the
Bible says about that all right great
thank you junith in Nevada junith
welcome to the program
program hello blessed
evening dog Andor Sean and I have a
question I I cannot find I don't know if
I miss the mark but I'm looking for that
fruit what is that fruit which is the
fruit of the TR of the knowledge of Good
and Evil is that an apple is that
another kind of fruit thank you yeah
thank you junith um you know P people
often picture uh they talk about Eve
eating the apple and I understand Apple
computer you know it's a picture of an
apple with one bite out of it it's it's
always red a red apple for some
reason so U you know that's become sort
of a logo for Eve eating the forbidden
fruit but nowhere in the Bible does it
call it an apple the uh the Old English
word for any kind of fruit would be
apple um and even in the Bible talks
about the apple of your eye it means
it's the center so it wasn't the typical
Macintosh or red delicious or Fuji apple
no no it's not it doesn't say what kind
of fruit it was for all we know it
looked like a cross between a a
pineapple and a pear and a banana we
don't know it probably was beautiful it
says it was you know good to look at
very attractive I think it looked much
better than the average Apple doesn't
describe the color though doesn't
describe the shape and it may have even
tasted great at first like all forbidden
fruit might taste good at first but U
the effect of that was devastating to
the the human race so no it's not a sin
to eat apples you know that's why they
say with a man and you get this lump in
your throat they call it the Adams Apple
because he took the fruit that Eve gave
him and I guess a piece got stuck there
that's the story anyway all right hey
thanks junith next caller that we have
is Anastasia listening from uh Canada
Anastasia welcome to the program hi hi
Pastor D hi Pastor Ross Hi how are you
I'm good I hope you're doing well um my
question was about um the four creatures
that um John saw in the vision um are
they symbolic or are there actually like
four creatures in heaven sitting in
front of the throne with eyes all over
them yeah well I think I think they're
symbols and Revelation plays on a lot of
the symbols you find other places in the
Bible and it's in Ezekiel CH 1 he
describes these four living creatures
that are almost identical to the
creatures that you find there in
Revelation and there's been great debate
and discussion uh on what these
creatures represent you know you know
they'd be kind of bizarre say one's got
like you know man's face and they got
wings and eyes and and uh horses hooves
and wheels within wheels and there's a
lot of symbolism in there um and I know
pastor
he and I maybe have a slightly different
view on this but uh I think both may be
applicable many of the church fathers
believe that these four creatures are
different attributes of Jesus that you
see in the gospels where the you know
the lion is Jesus being presented in the
Book of Matthew as a king it was written
for the Jews he's a messiah and in mark
it was appealing to the Gentiles the
Greeks and Jesus is portrayed the speed
and the vision of the eagle and uh in
Mark is a very quick gospel if you've
read it in Luke you've got the phys
there you have Jesus the man and in John
you've got Jesus who is the sacrifice
and so that's one way some people have
viewed it hey friends you hear the music
we're taking a break just came up and
hit us we'll be back don't go
anywhere stay tuned Bible answer live
will return
[Music]
shortly beasts plages and the cryptic
number 666 for many The Book of
Revelation is both frightening and
confusing does this last book of the
Bible really provide insight for the
final days or is it nothing more than an
ominous book of Doom and Gloom on the
contrary Revelation is as the title
suggests a revealing a power powerful
prophetic book filled with hope
encouragement and yes urgent messages of
final warning for our world friends
please join me Doug Bachelor as amazing
facts presents the Pinnacle of Prophecy
unlocking Revelations Mysteries starting
October 27 at 700 p.m. Pacific time you
can attend in person at the Granite Bay
Hilltop church and you can view the
programs on AFV Facebook YouTube and
more yes it's true you can know the
future for more information and to
register visit Pinnacle
oppr you can become a Bible expert with
the amazing facts storical of Prophecy
Bible study experience now available in
18 languages these 24 easy to read
lessons will give you confidence about
what the bible really says about last
day prophecy the afterlife and so much
more even better it's absolutely free at
stoic. org don't miss out get the
answers you need for a happier healthier
life today at storical
[Music]
dog find out what the critics are raving
about top Scholars and theologians from
around the country come together to
reveal the hidden history of the Book of
Revelation with powerful reenactments
and incredible visual effects this
95-minute masterpiece brings to life the
Book of Revelation like never before
Revelation is no longer a mystery get
your copy today this visit iTunes or AF
bookstore.com
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life
today if you have a question about the
Bible or living the Christian Life call
us now at 800 God says that's 800
N7 now let's rejoin our hosts for more
Bible answers
live hello listening friends we are back
for Bible answers live we're going to
take some more questions in just a
moment this is a live International
interactive Bible study that uh you're
invited to call in with your questions
we usually budget about three minutes
per question to cover as much as we can
can as many questions as quickly and yet
being as thorough as we can but before
we go to the liines pastor Ross I
thought we'd highlight something that
people maybe heard about during the
break absolutely we're excited about
this a new prophecy series called I'm
going to hold up the flyer Pinnacle the
Pinnacle of Prophecy and this going to
begin coming up in just a few weeks the
27th of October and it's going to be
live 7 o'clock Pacific time broadcast on
a number of outlets and you can see they
on the screen the various Outlets and
you know this is a great thing for
people to invite their friends to we're
going to be looking at the heart of the
prophecy in the Book of Revelation
Revelation chapter 14 a lot of people
are wondering about end time events with
the conflict in the Middle East and it
could spill over and involve other
nations is there anything significant
how does that relate to Bible prophecy
so this is a great event to invite your
friends
to yeah open your home open your church
you just turn on either AFV it'll be
streaming online a number of sit if you
want to know more information about the
dates just go to amazing facts there's
also a website called Pinnacle of
Prophecy but uh you can also just go to
amazing facts I think it's on our our
main page there and click on it it'll
give you all the details you can
download the lessons and join in this
seminar for free all right excellent
next caller that we have is Russell and
Russell are listening in California
Russell you on the
air yeah my name is Russell and I have a
question
it's um was was there a big connection
between the Tower of Babel and
Babylon great question yes the uh the
word Babel and Babylon are actually
connected um I've understood that that
the term Babylon meant like Gate of
Heaven where the word Babel is connected
with the word confusion and that's where
we get the modern word for baby and and
babene because a baby
babbles um in many languages baby's a
baby but uh in any event um the site of
the Tower of Babel is the same place
where the ancient city of Babylon was
built and there was a historian called
Herodotus that said that King
Nebuchadnezzar when he was building his
Temple they took some of the ancient
stones from the original Tower of Babel
and they used it as interior fill to
build up the zigurat that Nebuchadnezzar
built and so they were in the same
location and they're in Mesopotamia and
of course the city of babyl or Babylon
has um symbolic significance you find it
very early in the Old Testament and it
represents a confusion of religion and
opposition to the truth and then you
find Babylon appearing in the old test
well in New Testament in a symbolic form
in Revelation chap 17 so B represents
the enemies of God and the confusion of
religion whereas Jerusalem would
represent a worship of the true God and
the truth is found in the law and in the
word of God so uh sometimes the Old
Testament has been referred to as A Tale
of Two Cities Babylon and Jerusalem very
interesting symbolism that we see there
yeah all right next caller that we have
is e Frank listening in New York e Frank
welcome to the program yes uh thank you
uh Pastor Ross and Pastor Bachelor for
taking my uh call this evening M I want
to ask a question that I can't really
decipher from scripture it's something
that I I've been trying to figure out
but I can't figure it out too well it
has to do with um the Old Testament and
Jesus is there any Scripture or passages
in the Old Testament that indicate that
Jesus was going to have a Ministry with
the 12 um what they call it in other
faiths the apostles but the 12 12 uh uh
disciples is it uh predicted in the Old
Testament as a fact that that was going
to occur or is that the Old Testament
New Testament are different covenants
that do not indicate what was going to
happen in general yeah I appreciate that
um you know probably one of the places
that you could look for a parallel in
the Old Testament was the Bible tells us
that um Moses had 12 princes and they
chose 12 Representatives for the 12
tribes when he was leading them to the
promised land and he had 70 elders well
Jesus had 12 Apostles and he had 70
disciples that he sent out in the Gospel
of Luke tells us um I'm trying to think
this if there was any you know talks
about the Teaching Ministry of Jesus in
the Old Testament but I don't know that
it says and he would have 12 Apostles so
there's no specific prophecy that said
that but we do see parallels we do see
King Solomon and David surrounded
themselves with leadership in the number
12 or divisions of that number and there
were like you know uh 12 cycles of
priests or they had 24 that's why you
get the number 144,000 is 12 time
12,000 there were they many people count
when you look at the judges if you
include Samuel as one of the judges
there were 12
judges so um you see that number is a
number that represented God's people and
um I think even Peter says I'm sending a
letter to the 12 tribes and he's using
it there to talk to the church but he
calls them the 12 tribes so the number
12 we find in the Bible represents God's
people Old Testament 12 tribes New
Testament 12 Apostles and of course we
find in Revelation 12 that there is a
woman represented the church and she has
a crown of 12 Stars so again 12
connected with God's people all right
next caller that we have is Abby
listening in Utah Abby welcome to the
program um hi my name is it is Abby um
my Bible question is um why do most
people choose Sunday as a holy day
instead of
Saturday yeah all right thank you good
question um first of all in the Bible
the Jews did not use the names that we
typically use today for you know we use
uh names connected with Roman and Greek
deities Sunday the sun was the principal
uh God that was worshiped even in the
Egyptians Mondays moonday Wednesday was
Odin's day Thursday was Thor's day
Saturday was Saturn day the Bible they
called it 1 2 third fourth fifth then
the sixth was called preparation day
preparation for the Sabbath seventh day
was called the Sabbath day but they used
numbers and so um God blessed the
seventh day of the week that's the day
we normally call Saturday Jesus rose on
the first day of the week There's no
question that he rose on what we would
call Sunday but did he ever changed the
Sabbath from Saturday to Sunday well
there's no verse in the scripture
anywhere where we are commanded to keep
Sunday as a holy day uh some people have
looked at a couple of verses in the New
Testament that mentioned the first day
of the week and they had Gatherings but
it also says they gathered every day in
other places so um Sunday keeping really
came from Traditions that began to grow
several hundred years after Jesus and
the apostles and they're not based on
any commandment in the Bible we have a
study guide It's called the last day of
history and it talks about the Sabbath
and Sunday and how the change occurred
we'll be happy to send that again to
anyone who calls and asks the number is
800 835 6747 or dial pound 250 on your
smartphone say Bible aners live and ask
for the study guide by name it's called
The Lost day of History yes all right we
got John listening in Ohio John welcome
to the
program yes good evening pastors evening
my question is um are the Jews that we
see in Jerusalem now are they the ones
that came out of the Exodus or are they
Europeans who converted over to Judaism
and moved back to Jerusalem after it was
abandoned by the
Romans yeah uh well what happened is the
Romans scattered the Jews and God
foretold this what happened they called
it the theoria the the Jews really
that's where you get the idea of the
wandering jew um 10 of the tribes of
Israel were carried off to Assyria long
before Jesus was born and sometimes they
refer to him as the 10 lost tribes well
they weren't really lost they largely
intermarried with the Assyrians and uhu
you know they pretty much were absorbed
uh whereas the Jews and that comes from
the tribe of Judah is where you get the
word um they were scattered but they
continued to live in enclaves this is
where we get the word ghetto in Italy
they made all the Jews live in a place
called ghetto and uh now we use that
word to talk about you all kinds of
ethnic ghettos but it was really a
Jewish Enclave because they had to go
before dark they had to be back in their
City terribly persecuted but they did
largely remain unique and intermarried
with other Jews they were very uh
careful about that there was some
intermarriage with other races you can
tell from Jewish DNA today but we know
with some certainty because of DNA that
the the Jews and they you know they've
got some influence in some blood from
people they've lived among around the
world but they are the original Jews
that were the semetic people that lived
in the land of Israel and yes many of
them did end up in Russia in Germany in
Europe in Italy and U everywhere you go
in the world now you can find a
synagogue just about and if I think we
mentioned this last week the largest
concentration of Jews in the world today
is not in Israel but actually in the
United States yep and then second would
be Israel hotpots in the North America
would be New York City Florida and in
Los Angeles and then
Chicago so U and then I think 40% are in
Israel right the rest are scattered
around the planet but yet they are the
Jews of the Bible now are the people
living in Egypt now the same ones that
built the pyramids No that's a
completely different race so uh I just
want to share that since you're asking
and if you'd like to learn more about
what the says about this we've got a
book called spiritual Israel and of
course we'll send that to anyone who
calls and asks 800 835 6747 ask for the
book it's called spiritual Israel all
dial pound 250 say Bible answers live
and then spiritual Israel Rebecca in
Michigan Rebecca you are on the air
welcome hello how you guys doing good
thank you for calling what's your
question
tonight um I have a a question I'm
having I'm having um physical and mental
health problems adversities and it
brings along with spiritual
problems and and I need I need PR I need
prayer and a couple of Bible Bible
verses to get my mind off it all right
well let's see if we can help you with
that uh we'll pray in just a moment but
some Bible verses would be it says uh
Jesus said let not your heart be
troubled this is John chapter 14 let not
your heart be troubled neither Let It Be
Afraid you believe in God believe also
in me in my father's house are many
mansions I go to prepare a place for you
don't let the Troubles of this world
frighten you because if you give your
life to Christ this world's temporary
God's offering you a world that lasts
forever the Bible says that God offers
us a peace that passes understanding I
recommend you read the book of Philip
Philippians I just finished reading
Philippians or I'm almost done and it's
just a book of joy and uh it Paul just
is he's bubbling over with joy and why
Christians should have joy and peace
that passes understanding so you do that
Rebecca and let me pray for you right
now and uh those listening can join as
well Father in heaven we just want to
lift a prayer right now in behalf of
Rebecca I give her peace I pray that
you'll just U chase away the clouds or
any evil influence might be tormenting
her and giving her distress and I pray
your spirit will be released in her life
and just help her to sense your presence
your angels about her and peace in her
heart we ask in Jesus name amen amen
Pastor Doug we have a book it's called
peace in the midst of the storm yeah ABS
we'll be happy to send that to anyone
who calls and asks 800 835
6747 how to have peace in a world of
worry that yeah that's what I was going
to say what it is yeah yeah I've got
book on worry we got a picture of rain
on the front so I thought storm but it's
actually yeah sermon mixed up with a
book yeah that's what it is I I have a
book and it's called how to have peace
in a world of worry and that will bring
you peace Rebecca I think that will help
it's free if you ask for it 800 835 6747
again is the number and of course you
can dial pound 250 ask for the book how
to have peace in a world of worry yeah
we've got Shawn listening in Michigan
sha welcome to the
program thank you so much for taking my
call yeah I have a question uh in regard
to the timing of the seventh year of the
king Artis Xerxes I've often heard it's
457 BC but someone had sent me like an
introduction to the book of Nehemiah and
it was from like a certain analytical
Bible dictionary and it said that that
was 458 BC and I didn't know if there's
any way to verify that from other
historical sources but I want to make
sure that it is 457 BC because I know
that relates to the time prophecy in
Daniel eight and nine yeah well first of
all um when you're looking back 2500
years I if you're six months off you're
doing pretty good so don't I wouldn't
stress over it but I believe it's
457 uh and the uh the history that I've
read and Pastor Ross you might have some
of the references at your fingertips but
you know I've read a lot of books about
this because it that year is actually p
for uh pinpointing the not only the uh
crucifixion of Jesus and the stoning of
Steven and the baptism of Jesus but you
could even go backwards 30 years knowing
that Christ would begin his ministry at
30 and get the birth of Jesus and so um
the only way it works is if it's 457 but
that's not the reason we believe it
happened I think that it's U documented
in history now there were three decrees
that talked about restoring and building
Jerusalem the final one is the decree of
AR Xerxes you find it here I'm looking
at it now in Ezra
7:12 and I'm sure you've seen that Sean
and I think one of the things in
addition to what Pastor Doug said how we
know it's 457 is if you do the math and
you go back into New Testament times we
know based upon the account given by
Luke we know when Jesus was baptized and
you trace that back and that was 27 ad M
and the only date that'll work if you
follow the prophecy in Daniel 9 it has
to begin in 457 BC you in order for
Christ to be baptized in 27 ad and then
die in 31 so all the pieces fit together
yeah one more thought is the issuing of
decrees in Bible times they did not fax
them so the king might actually sign a
decree and it becomes law when he signs
up Ezra may not get it for months
because of the the maale system from
Persia to Israel they had to come by
Caravan I mean so things did not happen
overnight there so there's a lot of
factors and also um when you begin and
end a year biblically um is a little
different the way the Persians did from
the Romans all right thank you next
caller that we have is Jerry in Oregon
Jerry welcome to the
program uh good evening pastors evening
my question pertains to the mark of the
beast described in Revelation 14 now
obviously the context of this is at the
end time before Jesus returned and
before the Millennium MH but it says
Those Who worship the
Beast they will be tormented with
burning sulfur in the presence of the
Holy Angels and of the lamb and the
smoke of their torment will rise forever
and ever there will be no rest day or
night for those who worship the Beast
and its image okay that's before the the
the uh Millennium then Revelation 20
talks about the resurrection of the
unrighteous and it says and the devil
who deceived them was thrown into the
lake of burning sulfur where the Beast
and the false prophet had been thrown
and they will be tormented day and night
forever and ever and then it talks about
the unjust going into the to the uh Lake
of Fire this is a second death so my
question is are those who worship the
Beast are
they're they're not are they excluded
from the the resurrection of the
unjust and uh do they do they suffer a
greater torment than the unjust in
Revelation 20 who who who realize the
second death in the Lake of Fire right
you know I think what'll solve this is
when you understand that Revelation is
not written in chronological order and
what's happening from one chapter the
next in Revelation they back up they
cover some of the same time period and
and it's the same event when it talks
about in Revelation 14 they have no rest
there or night it's talking about the
punishment of the wicked but then it
uses different Visions to say the same
thing there is only one time when the
wicked are cast into the Lake of Fire
and that is the same time as the devil
and the Beast and the false prophet and
all that follow the devil now proof for
that would be is if you look in uh
Matthew 25 where Jesus tells the parable
of the sheep and the goats he says that
those that are lost he says to the
unbelievers and the goats depart from me
cursed Into the Fire prepared for the
devil and his angels that's all at one
time so following the great white Throne
judgment there is a decree when all of
the wicked are cast into the Lake of
Fire and they are punished according to
what each one
deserves and it says the smoke of their
torment uh it rises up for ever and ever
and that that doesn't mean forever and
ever we're sitting there watching people
burn that'd be terrible thought it means
it rises up out of sight as far as you
can see and that was a picture they
would see often in ancient Wars The
Smoke ascended up forever meaning out of
sight um and that means that there
there's no reprieve no second option
it's called the second death and but it
all happens at the same time we have a
study gu it's called is the devil in
charge of Hell talks about the final
destruction of the wicked and covers
these Bible verses the number to call is
800 83567 47 ask for the study guide is
called is the devil in charge of hell
you can also dial pound 250 say Bible
answers live and then ask for that study
guide meline is listening in Nevada
meline welcome to the
program let's see one more time meline
in Nevada there we go hi meline yes hi
how you hi okay um my question
is I've um
I've been divorced four times my first
husband got remarried my second husband
got remarried my third husband stayed
with the woman that he was seeing while
we were married so their girlfriend and
boyfriend and my fourth husband got
remarried I've been alone single for 25
years I'm in my middle
60s if I met somebody would it be a sin
for me to get married again
well I don't know uh and it's not
because I don't know what the Bible says
um I you know it this is the kind of
thing where you should probably talk to
a pastor and and unpack with him what
some of the circumstances were um you
know for one thing I divorce is not the
unpardonable sin but it it usually
involves sin and usually involves
selfishness or sin on one or both
parties um you've got the woman that
Jesus spoke to there of Samaria where
she said I've had she had five husbands
and she was living with someone she
wasn't married to and he reveals to her
he's the Messiah so clearly you know
there's hope and Redemption now whether
she went home and marry the guy she was
living with doesn't say in the Bible but
I'm hoping she kicked him out or married
him um because you know God God means
for marriage to be a permanent
institution I'm sure that's what you
were hoping for each time that you got
married
I do have a book I wrote that talks
about some of the nuances of this and
what the Bible says about marriage
divorce and remarriage and that's the
title of the book we'll send you a free
copy if you'd like mine the book is
called marriage divorce and remarriage
the number to call is 8835
6747 be sure to ask for that book or
just dial pound 250 on your smartphone
if you're outside of North America just
go to the Amazing Facts website and you
can read the book for free right there
online Paul is listening in Tennessee
Paul welcome to the
program yes evening pastors thank you I
uh just had a a question I was hoping
you guys could just provide a little uh
Clarity here on a couple of verses I'm
confused on uh just one on why uh Jesus
says in Mark
12:27 he is not the god of the dead but
of the living and then in Romans 149
Paul says basically uh that he might be
Lord of both the dead and the living and
the living so uh any Clarity there will
be Grace yeah well when it tells us When
God says I'm the god of Abraham Isaac
and Jacob I'm not God the god of the
Dead the Lord does not look upon the
dead that are saved as dead he Jesus
said the hour is coming in which all
those that sleep in the grave Jesus said
our friend Lazarus is sleeping he looks
upon uh saved people that have what we'd
call it death Jesus says well they're
asleep because I'm going to raise them
with a glorified body' so um that I
think helps provide understanding but
when uh Paul says he's a god of the dead
and the living you know clearly there
are people that are dead and so Jesus is
speaking more metaphorically when he
says that you know there's no dead they
redeemed or not viewed as dead and of
course the context of that at least in
Mark chap 12 uh there were the Sadducees
that said there was no Resurrection they
didn't believe in a resurrection and
Jesus is saying well if there's no
Resurrection God is not the god of the
Dead but the god of the living meaning
that he will resurrect those who trust
in him so Christ is reaffirming the
doctrine or the teaching of the
Resurrection yeah and it says here when
Stephen was stoned it says he cried out
and said Lord do not charge them with
this sin and when he said this he fell
asleep I mean does that really mean that
he fell asleep while they were stoning
him or does it mean he died that's right
but he died in a safe condition so he's
just sleeping waiting for the
resurrection oh Pastor R we have got a
minute here do we get a real quick
question maybe well we can try who do we
have let's see um here we go Bobby in
California Bobby we got about a
minute yes hello my question was
regarding Revelation 3:9 I would like
some clarity on this because I'm not
sure what I'm reading all right let's
read that real quick in Revelation 3:9
it says indeed I'll make those of the
synagogue of Satan say they are Jews and
are not but lie indeed I'll make them
come and worship before your feet to
know that I have loved you well there
was a a group of apostate Christians and
you know true Christians Revelation
calls the children of Israel counterfeit
it says the synagogue of Satan and I
don't know if these were some from the
the nians which think God hates but uh
yeah and it's talking about those who
come and worship before your feet if you
look at the time frame here it is the
Church of Philadelphia when there was a
great Revival in studying the Bible and
studying Bible truth it did occur in the
Protestant nations of the Earth around
the early 1800s in particular and it was
recognized by other nations that God was
blessing for example the United States
and the other Protestant Nations and in
that sense it talks about those who are
opposed to the truth will come to an
understanding yeah very good hope that
helps a little bit we we needed to give
some quick answers for those that are
listening if you're on satellite
God bless you have a good evening and
we'll see you and study next week for
the rest of you you stay by we're coming
back for just a few moments of Rapid
Fire Bible
questions thank you for listening to
today's broadcast we hope you understand
your Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California Hello friends and welcome
back to Bible and ansers live we want to
thank those who stayed by for the email
questions that you sent in if you have
an email question you'd like to send us
it's just B questions
amazingfacts.org so Pastor D here is our
first question for this evening uh the
question is Robert asks Christians say
that they believe in God um and if he
tells us to do something he'll give us
the power to do it but Jesus said that
we need to be perfect as our father in
Heaven how do we do that well it's not
talking about being perfect as in like a
stainless steel robot if you read that
same verse there in the Gospel of Luke
it says be therefore merciful even as
your father in Heaven is merciful god
wants us to have a perfect love a
perfect mercy and to just completely
trust him all right another question
Alice asks does the bible say that Adam
and Eve ate from the Tree of Life and if
yes why didn't they become
immortal well uh immortality it seems
they needed to continue continue to eat
from that tree because the fact that uh
I'm sure when Adam and Eve were first
created and the time they spent in the
garden I'm surprised that they would eat
from the Tree of the knowledge of Good
and Evil and not have eaten from the
Tree of Life I think evidence that they
did eat from the Tree of Life is that
they and their immediate posterity lived
hundreds of years and that's why it
tells us the tree of life will be in the
new Earth we probably continue to come
at least once every couple hundred years
and eat it and then our final question
here Kenny's asking from Papa n Guin how
do I love God
more oh that's a great question well for
one thing it says that uh we love him
because he first loved us and so as we
behold his love for us uh our love for
him will grow the better we know him the
more we'll love him you read in Romans
chap 10 verse 17 it says faith comes by
hearing and hearing by the word of God
and so as we read about Jesus in the
word of God and we get to know him
better um that inspires us with love
it's the goodness of God that leads us
to repentance as we look at his love and
his goodness that leads us to repentance
and U it increases our love for him and
something else happens is as we share
God's goodness and love with other
people then it inspires us to love him
more when we look at the cross and we
see what he paid for us and his
sacrifice probably the best place to
witness and understand the sacrifice of
Jesus is by looking at the cross well
listening friends thank you for your
special questions you can still email
questions to us anytime during the week
but for the rest of you God bless we'll
study his word together again next
[Music]
week bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible
questions